And where are you right now, Michael?
I'm in Reno, Nevada.
Okay, are you at a blackjack table?
Where are you specifically?
(Sona laughing)
I'm in my office, actually.
I'm a consultant and a beverage educator.
I'm a spirits educator,
so I'm in my office
where I take most of my Zoom calls.
Oh, that's so funny,
'cause I heard that
you were a spirit guide
before you got on and I'm
realizing, I swear to god,
I thought you were a spirit guide.
You're a spirits guide.
You're a spirits educator.
The S is very important.
Yeah, because I'm sure there
are people that come to you
and say, can you help me find my,
I want to talk to my
great-grandfather and you say,
I can't do that, but I have
a really good port for you
that you might want to drink.
I do a fair amount of
necromancy, but not a great deal.
Like I try to limit the amount.
Man, here's another
thing, he says necromancy.
I know.
I love it.
I love anyone who knows
that word and says,
I am a necromancer.
It's such a menacing word
that no one uses anymore.
Lots of drama in that word.
Michael, tell me about this.
I'm interested in this.
You work with spirits.
What does that mean exactly?
Do you help develop types of drinks
or do you mostly do you study drinks?
What do you do?
All of it.
So my principle job is
as a spirits educator
is to talk and teach and
get people into products,
teach people new things about drinks.
I do beverage design for like menus.
I design bars.
And then my like full-time job I work
for a bartender advocacy agency,
which is like a PR firm
specifically for bartenders.
Whoa.
That's fascinating.
Now why do people need, I
mean, most people figure out
drinking pretty much
on their own, you know?
Don't you think most
people are self-taught
when it comes to alcohol.
They figure out what they like to drink
and then they have way too
much of it and they get sick.
What do you find that you're
teaching people about?
Sort of more of the refined
aspects of certain spirits?
I always say I'm the Sherpa
up the mountain of alcohol, right?
(Sona laughing)
So my job is to help you find
your new favorite friend.
(Conan laughing)
Okay, and what are your favorite drinks?
What drinks do you?
Tell us, what do you,
what's your favorite drink
that you find yourself
moving towards in life?
I mean, I love a piña colada.
I love rum.
So I like a piña colada
'cause they're fun.
Who doesn't want a piña colada?
But I love bourbon.
I help host a bourbon summer
camp that bartenders go to,
which is its own magical thing itself.
What?
A bourbon summer camp.
Yes.
This sounds so much better
than Craggett Mountain Farm,
where my parents sent me,
where there are peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches
and we had to climb the entire
Presidential Mountain Range
in July in New Hampshire
and be eaten to death
by mosquitoes and no one had invented
any kind of sun lotion
yet, so I just burned up
and became a massive pustule.
What you just described is a
much better camp, a rum camp.
It's bourbon.
Oh, bourbon, okay.
Whatever, it doesn't matter.
I'm gonna tell you something.
I have a huge fondness for rum.
I really do like rum and I like rum
in kind of a fruity punch.
And I'm probably not
supposed to admit that,
but I do like a fruity rummy drink,
or like a rum punch, a
planter's punch, if you will.
Why can't you admit that?
Because I also like it
when it has fruit in it
floating around and I like it when there's
like a little plastic statue in it too
that's on the top of a swizzle stick.
I like it to be a drink that
emasculates me immediately
the minute it's brought to my table,
those are my favorite drinks.
Big twisty straw.
I like a twisty straw.
I love all that stuff.